la primera mujer latina en haber sido
electa al senado de Estados Unidos Hace
seis años Fue reelecta tras una ajustada
Carrera contra el republicano Adam quien
fue apoyado además por Donald Trump su
Victoria lleva entonces a que los
demócratas aseguren las 50 sillas
necesarias para lograr la mayoría en la
cámara alta teniendo en cuenta que el
voto de desempate lo decide la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris la victoria
de Cortés masto se terminó definiendo en
el condado de Clark condado donde está
la ciudad de Las Vegas y donde todavía
se están contando más votos con esta
Victoria los demócratas ya no dependen
de la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
al senado en Georgia y además tendrán el
poder en los próximos años de confirmar
jueces federales y otros oficiales
públicos y abrir sus propias
investigaciones sin depender de la
cámara del representantes al respecto el
líder plata del senado Jack Summer dijo
en una rueda de prensa que esta era una
victoria de la agenda del partido
demócrata y de los estadounidenses que
se opusieron a candidatos extremistas
respaldados por Donald Trump